a little more than a year before his
death larry king scribbled out a will
but instead of clarity those final
wishes have created confusion
and lots of controversy a confusion
controversy and now a family battle
instigated by his wife sean king
clearly i think this is going to get
pretty ugly
we were partners in every sense of the
way
sean drew the battle lines today in this
new court filing
over her late husband's fortune it's
shawn versus
king's eldest son larry king jr and it's
all focused on this
unusual letter a secret handwritten
will it's very strange it's a very
strange thing to do
we showed it to law and crime legal
analyst rachel stockman
who says the document raises a lot of
questions
you can see a portion of it he crossed
over
but if this upholds it is clear that he
essentially cut his wife sean out
of his will the hard to read new will
says that
king wanted his five kids to get all of
his estate
and divide it equally last year two of
his children passed away
leaving just larry king jr and king's
two sons with sean
chance and cannon who reportedly stand
by their mom
another factor the timing the
handwritten will
is dated october of 2019 just two months
earlier
larry filed for divorce from sean after
22 years together
we never finalized our divorce i in my
heart didn't think it was really going
to happen and i just
never did she's likely going to argue
that larry was under some kind of
undue influence that someone was trying
to pressure him
or alternatively that he wasn't of sound
mind for whatever reason
when he wrote this so how much might be
at stake
well one report puts the broadcaster's
fortune at around 50 million dollars
in a court filing sean stated that in
2018
larry's gross monthly income before
taxes was
one million nine hundred thousand
dollars and
there's another twist in today's filing
sean claims she recently found the
broadcaster had a
secret account which benefited larry jr
there's a lot of unanswered questions
here that i'm sure will come to light as
this case
makes its way through court
you